let's attempt to evaluate the indefinite
integral of 1 over the square root of 1
minus x squared DX and you might be
tempted to use something like u
substitution here but you'll discover
very quickly that is not working out you
might say okay maybe I have this
function I just need to rivet it but the
derivative isn't sitting out here
someplace so instead we're going to use
a different technique and the technique
we're going to use is called trig
substitution so still still a form a
kind of it we're going to be doing some
substitutions we're going to use trig
functions and trig identities to try to
simplify this expression into something
that we can take the antiderivative of
and in this case we're going to leverage
the idea that sine squared theta plus
cosine squared theta is equal to 1 this
comes straight out of the unit circle
definition of trig functions or if you
subtract sine squared theta from both
sides you get cosine squared theta is
equal to one minus sine squared theta
and so you might immediately see a
pattern we have a 1 minus an x squared
we have one minus sine squared theta so
if we just set if we set X if we set X
to be equal to sine of theta X is equal
to sine of theta then 1 minus x squared
1 minus x squared would be equal to 1
minus sine squared theta and then we can
leverage this trig identity right over
here and say well that would be equal to
cosine squared theta which is pretty
convenient because it would be sitting
right here under a radical so that we
could didn't then take the principal
root of that so let's make that
substitution X is equal to sine of theta
later on we're going to have to undo the
substitution so let's solve for theta in
terms of X so let's say so if we take
the inverse sine of both sides we get
theta is equal to arc sine or inverse
sine arc sine of X and then this
automatically limits the range of Thetas
that we might have so you might say wait
aren't we limiting our exes because the
sine of theta can only produce an X
between 1 and negative 1 but that's
really just our domain here in fact we
can't even equal 1 or negative 1 then we
get 1 over 0 but in order for this
principal root to make any sense X has
to be so already over here our domain is
being restricted to X is
X has to be less than 1 and greater than
and greater than negative 1 in order for
what this stuff down here to make any
sense in order to evaluate the radical
we could have this greater than or equal
or less than or equal in order for the
radical to be evaluated but then if X
were equaling 1 or negative 1 the
denominator right over here would be 0
square root of 0 0 and you would have 1
over 0 so the domain for this entire
expression right over here is this right
over here so it's completely fine we're
actually not limiting the domain by
saying X is equal to sine of theta now
when we write it this way is theta is
equal to arc sine of X this does give us
a sense of the range that theta might
take on so arc sine as it's typically
defined will produce a theta it will
produce a theta that is between that is
less than or equal to positive pi over 2
and greater than or equal to negative
negative PI over 2 just as a little bit
of a review of the unit circle and to
visualize what the arc sine function is
doing that's our y-axis and that is our
x-axis if you imagine this is the unit
circle this is the unit circle this is
the unit circle right over there we're
giving a value between 1 and negative 1
so we're giving a value between between
1 and negative 1 into the arc sine
function and then the theta it gives it
could give a theta that responds to
something out here but so it's an actual
function it'll only give you the theta
it'll only give you a theta as its
traditionally defined that's between PI
over 2 and negative PI or two or between
negative PI over 2 and PI over 2 so
it'll only give you an angle that makes
you sit in the first or the fourth
quadrants which will be useful later on
because right over here for any of these
Thetas if we're sitting in the first or
fourth quadrant our x-coordinate is
always going to be positive so for any
of these Thetas for any of these Thetas
for any of these Thetas that we that we
hit cosine of theta is going to be
positive cosine of theta is going to be
greater than or equal to greater than or
equal to zero in any of these situations
it's going to be useful as we try to
simplify this expression so let's try to
substitute back and the only thing we
have left to do we already know that X
is equal to sine theta theta is equal to
arc sine of X but we also have to figure
out what D
x is equal to we also need to figure out
what DX is equal to we could say DX d
theta is going to be equal to the
derivative of this with respect to theta
which is just cosine theta or we could
write that DX is equal to cosine theta D
D theta now we can substitute everything
here in terms of or replace everything
that's in terms of X here we can replace
them in terms of theta so our original
expression becomes the antiderivative of
and instead of writing 1 times D X in
the numerator I'll just write this
cosine theta D theta so let me write
this cosine theta cosine theta I'll
write the D theta right out here cosine
D theta cosine theta D theta all of
that's going to be over the square root
of 1 minus x squared we already know
that one minus x squared is 1 minus sine
squared theta which is cosine squared
theta which is cosine squared theta and
I think you see where this is going now
we have to be careful here if i have the
square root of x squared this is equal
to the absolute value of x if x is
positive this is just going to be equal
to the x 3 squared the principal root of
that is just positive 3 if x is negative
if you have negative 3 squared that goes
to positive 9 you take the principal
root you get positive 3 so you're
essentially taking the absolute value of
x now what's useful here so you based on
that we would say that the square root
the square root of cosine squared theta
is equal to the absolute value of cosine
theta but lucky for us we have already
limited theta 2 values where cosine of
theta is going to be non-negative so
this because cosine of theta is greater
than or equal to 0 this is going to be
just equal to cosine theta so then this
whole thing simplifies to this is equal
to our blue cosine theta our blue cosine
theta over our green cosine theta this
simplifies to the absolute value of
cosine theta which is just cosine theta
since cosine theta is positive d theta D
theta cosine theta over cosine theta is
1 is 1 so our whole integral has
simplified to the indefinite integral
d theta which is equal to or we could
say it's of one D theta if we like which
is equal to theta which is equal to
theta plus C and you can verify this
take the derivative of this with respect
to theta is 1 and this is just 0 so this
makes sense but we want our answer in
terms of X now do we just have to undo
the substitution we have data is equal
to arc sine of X so this is going to be
equal to arc sine arc sine of X arc sine
of X plus plus C just like that and we
are done and by doing this problem we've
also helped figure out what the
derivative of arc sine is if you think
about it that way but we'll do more and
more examples of these that get
progressively more complicated but this
is a major pattern to see when you see
one minus x squared or else we'll see if
you see an a squared minus x squared
where is some constant that's a pretty
good sign that you'd want to substitute
with X is equal to let's say sine of
theta